We're going to start today by
talking about the enlightenment.
And I want to offer one,
uh,
prefatory caution about any way of
dividing up the history of ideas anyway of
period Ising if you like
the history of ideas,
which is that there's no single
right way to do that. And indeed,
uh,
anyway,
you do it obscures in some
ways important things.
So for example,
sometimes people dry it divide up the
history of western political thought into
the ancients and the moderns and the
ancients asserts thought to have certain
characteristic preoccupations that
change around sometime around the 16th
century with Macchia valley or was or in
the 17th century with some of the folks
we're going to be talking about today.
And so we get this picture presented
that there's a fundamental difference
between ancients and moderns.
On the other hand,
another way of dividing up the history
of the tradition is between naturalists
and anti naturalists.
So natural as some people who think that,
uh,
understanding nature and understanding
human nature is the key to political
theorizing. Whereas Auntie naturalists
look for something else, whether it's,
um, God's law or transcendental, um,
platonic forms or something like that.
And so we can have a division
of the tradition in, in, uh,
between naturalists who generally trace
all the way back to Aristotle and anti
naturalists to trace all
the way back to Plato.
It's not that the distinction between
naturalists and anti naturalists is better
or, or more accurate than the
distinction between ancients and moderns.
It's just a different kind of distinction
that highlights different features of
these thinkers, um,
for different purposes.
So I just say that as a caution because
now we're focusing on the enlightenment
as a characteristic move in
western political thinking
that really starts in the
17th century and comes into
its own in the 18th century.
But I don't want you to reify that idea.
Um,
these enlightenment thinkers we're
talking about do in fact have important,
um, points of continuity with
many evil and ancient thinkers,
um, some of which will come up
in our discussions. Nonetheless,
I think it's useful to focus on the
enlightenment as a distinctive turn in
western political thinking.
And that's going to structure
our discussion going forward.
And the first three traditions we're
going to consider in this course,
namely utilitarianism,
Marxism and the social contract are
all variants of enlightenment thinking.
But before we get into the nitty
gritty of those traditions,
I want us today to take a step back
and think more generally about what the
enlightenment was.
What this enlightenment move is that
I'm pointing to as setting the outer
philosophical boundaries of these first
three traditions that we're going to be
considering starting next Wednesday.
Okay.
And as I said in my introductory lecture,
the enlightenment really evolves at
twin commitment as far as politics is
concerned.
And that is to first and foremost a
commitment to science as the basis for
theorizing about politics,
a commitment to science rather than a
commitment to tradition or religion or a
revelation or um,
anything else.
Um, rather the idea was
that the, that science,
um,
is going to provide the right incentives
for thinking about the correct
political organization of society.
And secondly that the core political
value for enlightenment thinkers is this
notion of individual freedom
to be operationalized or
realized through a doctor
doctrine of the rights of the individual.
We'll see a shortly that one of the
distinctive moves of the 17th century ride
is about politics,
is that they stopped talking so much about
natural law and start instead to talk
about natural rights,
the rights of the individual to realize
their purposes through politics.
And so the enlightenment,
as I said,
revolves around this twin commitment to
the idea of importance of science as the
basis for theorizing and the importance
of individual freedoms realized through
a doctrine of individual rights.
And we're going to use John Locke as
a window into this early enlightenment
thinking separately,
initially from his role as one of the
early social contract theorists that will
be dealing with in a few weeks.
Um,
but first we're going to
focus on this idea of science.
Now let's think about what science is,
what it's all about.
I have three diagnostic questions
here and the reason I put them up,
we'll become playing in a second.
It has to do with the fact that
the early enlightenment theorists,
the 17th century theorists thought
that the hallmark of genuine knowledge,
the hallmark of science was certainty.
You might all have come across in
one philosophy course or another.
The famous car Tz and idea
Descartes' idea. Does anybody,
anyone read Descartes who can
tell us what is most famous for?
Okay.
The what?
The Calgary Tower did you say?
Yeah, Descartes. What? What was his idea?
Systematic doubt. W you're
dead, right? Why? Why did,
why was he interested in doubting things?
Anybody.
Why did they card?
This is a,
this is a bonus question cause
stay card is not on the syllabus,
but why was he interested in China
about things? What was he looking for?
Yeah,
he was looking for what you
can truly be certain about it.
Exactly.
He was looking for absolute certainty
that the hallmark of genuine knowledge is
certainty.
So it's asking himself what is it
that we can have certainty about?
And as you probably now, Descartes
had his own answer to that question.
What was it? I think therefore
I am correct. I am a Yaley.
Therefore I am right. Yeah.
I think therefore I am.
And he thought he,
they card thought this was an,
this was said particular
kind of proposition because
the very act of trying to
doubt it affirmed. You
couldn't, you couldn't direct,
you know,
and so that was what the early
enlightenment theorists we're looking for.
What is it that makes knowledge
certain puts it beyond doubt.
And so I've got up here three propositions
and we could say the sum of the
Interior angles of a
triangle equals 180 degrees.
Okay.
How many people think that that
proposition can be known with certainty?
Yeah, a lot. I mean, how would
you try and doubt it? You know,
you could measure one triangle measured
the next triangle, measure third.
You know, after you had measured
5,604 triangles, you'd start to say,
hmm, maybe there's a theorem
here. Maybe this, you know,
it's not as if the,
the,
the next triangle I find is going to turn
out not to add up to 108 it's just not
going to happen. Right. We know.
And that's what we've come to refer to
in modern philosophical thinking as a
priore knowledge. If follows from
the nature of the definitions,
nature of the terms
that,
um,
the proposition of force campie down,
it's all if we say a bachelor
is an unmarried man, you know,
you're not going to go and start looking
at bachelor after bachelor to see if
you can find a married bachelor. There's
no such thing as a married bachelor.
So those propositions we tend to think
of today as analytic propositions.
They follow analytically from
the definitions of the terms,
uh,
at issue or in a true this of mathematics.
It seems there's a theorem that tells
you it must be the case that the sum of
the interior angles of a
triangle add up to 180 degrees.
When we say come to what
I've numbered to here,
how many people think that that
can be known with certainty?
Some of you do.
Anyone not so sure.
Why? Why are you unsure? Where's the
microphone? What's the source of your,
your your doubt? Yeah. Okay.
Well, it seems like, um,
in terms of geology when we weren't able
to penetrate what was underneath the
earth for a long period of time and the
knowledge of tectonic plates even was a
new or more modern,
um, discovery, I guess.
Right?
So I think that's exactly right.
The current bashed empirical understanding
of earthquakes is that it's the
movement of tectonic plates. But we
might, you know, science might advance,
there might be changes in
geology, uh, which, which,
which might lead us eventually
to learn. Well, yes,
some earthquakes result from
10 tonic plate movement,
but other earthquakes might
result from something else.
All we will learn that something moves
the tectonic plates that we don't
currently know about. This is an
ongoing process of empirical discovery,
right? It's, it's not the,
it's not a proposition that follows from
the nature of the terms and these we
call empirical propositions in Mar,
in modern philosophy of science. Um,
sometimes they called,
if you like the fancy Latin terminology,
a pastaria. Right. As opposed to a priore.
They're not analytical propositions.
Right.
They had their result of observation
and trying to figure out what the causes
are behind those phenomena.
So generally speaking,
they don't have the same kind of
force as analytic propositions.
What about this third one?
Consent is the basis for
political legitimacy.
Anyone think that can
be known with certainty?
Nobody.
I think that's right.
Most people would say,
wow,
that's a moral or a normative
judgment of some kind.
Maybe people agree with it,
maybe they don't,
but certainly it's not a
scientific proposition,
at least not obviously a
scientific proposition. Indeed.
Even if we, you know, even if we
took a, just in a descriptive sense,
not to mean consent should be the
basis of political legitimacy,
but as a descriptive matter about
regimes, some people would say, wow,
maybe regimes are based on consent,
but maybe some regimes
are based on other things.
Maybe they're based on
claims to divine authority.
Maybe that based on utilitarianism,
we're going to talk about that next week.
So it seems even as a descriptive matter,
never mind as a normative matter.
This is not a scientific proposition in
the way that a causal statements about
the world I scientific propositions and
certainly not in the way that analytical
statements about the world
can have scientific certainty
so we could spend more
time on this and there I did nuances
in modern conceptions of science that I
haven't gotten to that would paint a
more complex picture of the differences
among these three propositions.
But what I want to draw your
attention to now is that in the early
enlightenment,
17th century thinkers about the
nature of Science Day card and his
contemporaries thought very
differently about science.
Indeed
in the early enlightenment,
they would have agreed that the sum of
interior angles of a triangle equals 180
degrees is a proposition that
can be known with certainty.
But interestingly,
they would have this claim
here in the same category.
They would have put this claim about
consent in the same category with
propositions about mathematics
propositions behind which
there's a theorem as we
just said,
but when we're talking about triangles
and they would have relegated empirical
and causal claims
to an inferior status.
Now you might think that is pretty weird,
at least prima facie that seems pretty
weird and in order to get your mind into
the world in which they lived,
you have to suspend disbelief for a moment
about your concept of science and try
to get your mind around early
enlightenment conceptions of science which
involved thinking very different me.
The reason is that only enlightenment
thinkers wouldn't say that this is certain
because of the meanings of the words,
but rather it's certain because
this an act of well behind it.
Now this may sound even weirder
than anything I've said so far,
but consider
consider this passage here written by
Thomas Hobbs who is riding in the middle
of the 17th century in his in a minor
piece that he wrote the six lessons for
the professors of mathematics.
It's just not one of Hobbs is major works,
but I think it's,
it's one of the most succinct
descriptions I've ever seen of the early
enlightenment conception of science.
He says of the arts,
which for him is a general
term to capture knowledge.
He says some are demonstrably others
are in demonstrable and demonstrable.
Are those the construction
of where of the subject,
the construction of the subject,
where are is in the power of the artist
himself who in his demonstration does
know more about the deduce the
consequences off his own operation.
The way the reason we're,
I've is this,
that the science of every subject is
derived from a pre cognition of the causes
generation and construction of the same.
And consequently where
the courses are known,
there is place for demonstration but
not where the courses are to seek for
geometry.
Therefore,
it's demonstrably wall for the lines and
figures from which we reason are drawn
and described by ourselves.
We make the triangle.
Okay.
And civil philosophy is demands trouble
because we make the Commonwealth
ourselves.
Okay.
So this is the key to this what seems
like a very weird conception of political
philosophy as equivalent to um,
mathematics.
Civil Philosophy.
It's demonstrably cause we
make the Commonwealth House
House bought off natural
bodies. We know not the construction,
but seek it from the effects.
There lies no demonstration of
what the causes B we seek for,
but only what they may be,
only what they may be.
There's not going to be
certainty about earthquakes,
about the courses are earthquake.
We can make a probabilistic judgment,
we can make empirical claims,
but at the end of the day,
those claims are fallible.
That car at your ball,
they might have to be revised in the face
of future knowledge and science is not
going to ever reach to the level of
certainty with propositions of that sword.
And so this is why,
going back to this,
I did this ordering of these
street propositions on,
on a Hobbsy and view,
these two are equivalent not
because of anything about their,
I'm so analytics,
but rather because this will centerdness.
They're the product of the,
of human conscious action.
We make the triangle and
we make the Commonwealth.
And so we have privileged access
into the what goes into that making.
But we,
we don't make the planet.
God made the planet and we
can only observe the effects
of earthquakes and then
try and guess about their causes.
Right?
So
when we come to John Locke,
who is a at one with Hobbes
on this point about knowledge,
the term I want to use to capture this
early enlightenment conception of science
is the workmanship ideal,
right?
Rather than a priore or
analytic, uh, knowledge.
We're going to talk about knowledge in
terms of this idea of workmanship maker's
knowledge.
And it's important to realize
that in its ultimate foundations,
this is actually a theological
proposition, both for Hobbs.
We're going to leave hubs
behind now because you didn't
read him and we're going
to focus on lock. But as I
said, they have, they have, um,
the same view on this particular question.
So God has intimate knowledge of
the universe because he created it.
Okay.
And that is this,
this idea that making is a
source of knowledge, right?
So God knows God knows the
causes of earthquakes because he,
he made the earth. We don't because
we didn't make the art, but we can,
we can have God like knowledge of what
we create because God gave us the power
to create things. So this is in the
first instance, a theological argument.
Okay? So we are like miniature gods
with respect to what we create.
We have the same kind of make as knowledge
over what we create as God has over
what he created.
Now there are some constraints on our
kind I'll kinds of knowing
because we are also made by God.
And I were to get to that in a minute.
But what he,
what he did for human beings that he
didn't do for any aspect of creation
unlocks taling is that he gave
us this creative capacity.
Ah,
he gave us the capacity to behave
like miniature gods in the world.
And I'll come back to that.
Um, but I did want to,
to alert you to the fact that Phil Laak,
this was actually something now,
but tormenting idea. Um, we'll have,
we'll see a lot more about locked later.
But one of the most important
things you need to remember,
route lock is that he
was a Tomez. It was, uh,
a believing Christian
theologians throughout his life.
And there was a huge debate
that had gone on actually for,
uh, two centuries before Locke
wrote, among theologians.
And this was the puzzle that
they were worried about.
The question was,
can God change natural law?
If you said no,
that would suggest that
God is not omnipotent.
But if you said yes,
that would suggest that natural law
is not a system of timeless universals
because if God could change natural law,
maybe it's going to,
he'll choose to change it tomorrow.
And as we were talking
about, uh, on Wednesday,
remember when somebody asks me
about, uh, legal positivism,
I said that, uh, that was a doctrine
red rejected the idea of natural law.
The idea of natural law was that there
are some timeless universals that weekend
appeal to,
to judge actual political institutions
so we can appeal to natural law and the
context or the icon problem.
We were discussing to say
that Nazi Germany was a,
was an evil regime
right?
By we appeal to this high end natural law.
Well lock had been concerned about,
uh,
this,
this theological problem with natural
law that if you say it's a timeless
universal that seems to undermine the
idea of God's omnipotence because God
can't be an all powerful,
um,
okay
Vega, but are if on the other
hand you say, well, God, uh,
can change natural law then that that
undermines its possible universality and
lock struggled with this.
If you become experts on the 17th century
and you go back and read his essays on
the law of nature written in the 1660s,
uh,
you'll see him really torturing
himself, uh, as to how to resolve this.
He never really resolved that.
But in the end he came down on what we're
going to call the, the command theory,
the workman ship ship theory,
the well based theory that he said,
we have to say that God is omnipotent
and let the chips fall where they may for
the timelessness of a natural law.
It was never entirely comfortable with it,
but he couldn't let go of that proposition
for reasons I've already alluded to
that he thought something
couldn't have the,
the force of a law without
being the product of a will.
And so it's God's well that's the basis
of natural law and God's case and God's
knowledge,
uh,
office creation is traced back to this,
this idea of the workmanship
ideal maker's knowledge.
So God has make us
knowledge of his creation.
We're going to see, uh, two
important either features,
additional features of this workmanship
ideal that I'm just going to mention now
and then I'll come back to um,
one is that a translates over also
into normative considerations.
That is to say not only does
God have worked medicines,
Workman's knowledge creators
knowledge of what he creates,
but he also owns what he creates.
He has rights over his creation.
We are God's property
because he created us.
The world is God's property.
The Universe is God's property.
You own what you make.
God made everything.
So ultimately God owns everything.
And just as we can behave as miniature
gods and understanding our creation,
we can also behave as miniature
gods in owning what we make.
So we will see later this affects his
theory of property and his theory of the
state because we are going to have
rights over the state, which we create.
We're going to get to all of that later.
Okay. But so it's a unified theory,
this workmanship ideal that goes both
to the question of knowledge and to the
question of ownership rights,
entitlements,
everything is traced back
to this workmanship ideal.
The second point that I'm just
going to mention now and will,
it will come up later,
uh, it'll come up, uh,
most dramatically when we
come to consider marks.
Is that what gave lock it's theory,
it's internal coherence,
was that it was a theological argument.
None of this really makes any sense unless
you start from this proposition that
God created the universe and has make us
knowledge and make us a authority over
the universe. You know, everything
flows from that. As I said, uh, in,
in locks understanding, he gave us, um,
okay,
this unique capacity to create as well.
Um,
but we are answerable to him in
ways that that'll come up later.
But none of this makes sense without
the theological assumptions behind it.
Okay.
One of the big projects
of the enlightenment,
which is going to concern us one way or
another throughout the course is what
happens if you try to secularize
the workmanship ideal.
That is to say, you'll see in
the labor theory of value, uh,
that Mark's embraces,
which is at the core of his political
theory and modern social contract
theorists like Nozick and
Rawls and many others.
What what you're going to find is that
people want to hold onto this basic
structure of thinking.
People find this workmanship ideal,
intuitively very appealing,
but they're going to try and detach it
from its theological moorings because,
uh,
they,
they either don't believe the theological
argument for one reason or another,
or they find it problematic or
they wanted to convince people
that this idea that making creates
ownership is powerful and important
regardless of your religious convictions.
And so one of the big
challenges and projects of the
enlightenment is gonna turn
out to be how,
if at all,
can we retain the structure of this
workmanship ideal while shedding?
It's in its theological foundations,
but that's getting ahead of ourselves.
So what I want the takeaway point for,
for today to be is that this is the early
enlightenment conception of science.
It's a workmanship ideal
that appeals to certainty,
which was the Cartesian,
um,
preoccupation in the
Hobbs and preoccupation.
But it does it in a different way.
It doesn't look for what we today think
of as analytic propositions. Rather,
it looks for propositions that can be
known with certainty because we introspect
into our own will and understand
with certainty what we have created.
Okay?
And now let's,
yeah,
start to transition to talking
about individual rights.
And we do this by moving from God's
knowledge of his creation to God's
ownership, his creation. Just
to sum up this work on ship.
Ideal Locke
says,
the state of nature has a
law of nature to governance,
which obliges everyone and reason
which is that Lord teachers,
all mankind who will buck consulted,
that being all equal and independent,
no one ought to harm went out of his
life, health, liberty, and possessions.
I'll come back to that.
For men being all the workmanship of one
omnipotent and infinitely wise makeup,
all the servants of one sovereign Ma
Mazda sent into the world by his order and
about his business.
They are his property whose workmanship
they are made to last during his,
not during one another's pleasure.
And being furnished with faculties,
sharing all in one community of nature
that cannot be supposed any such
subordination among us that may authorize
us to destroy one another as we were
made for one another,
as if we were made for one.
And we're now this uses as the inferior
ranks and creatures are four hours.
So
this idea should give
you a sense in which, um,
Locke's theory of individual
rights are basic, uh,
and are rooted in the workmanship ideal.
We are God's creations. We are
his property. And that means,
you know,
as he says here,
we can't be one and now this
property we can own one another.
You might or you might say, well,
well don't parents make that children
don't parents own their children?
And indeed Sir Robert filmer that Locke
who lock was arguing against in the
first treaties took exactly the view
that parents own their children.
But film I had a very different conception
of the theological foundations of the
universe. Velma, who was
a defender of absolutism.
Um,
Elma said God gave the world to
Adam and his ass through a system of
primogenitor or inheritance.
And so there were a lot of folks running
around in 17th century England for
example, say Yang. Well,
I can, if you pay me,
I can prove that you're a closer
descendant of Adam than the next guy.
This was the notion that,
uh,
the lineage to Adam was important and
indeed that the kings and Queens of Europe
got their political authority
because they were direct descendants,
the most direct living descendants
of Adam and eve. So it was,
it was this idea God gave the world, uh,
to add him to, and he, to his children,
children, children, and in
absolute is thought there was,
they very seriously the idea that,
that pet parents own their children
and can indeed solve them into slavery,
uh, or worse, uh, because that
their property, Locke says, no,
God makes the child and users
the parents as his instrument.
The parents simply act out an
urge that's implanted in them,
but they can't a fashion the
anchor intricacies of the child.
And of course they can't
put a soul in the child.
So the child is God's creation
and we are all God's creation,
uh,
unlike
the view developed by filmer.
And so when we think about the
doctrine of individual rights,
um,
the first thing to see is that this
workmanship idea gives us at fundamental a
different status than anything that
it existed before in Weston political
thinking.
Because we are created by God,
we're all equal in the sight of God,
and we have the capacity to
function as miniature gods, um,
because of this capacity to
create things that we have.
Right?
Secondly,
we're all equal before God.
We're equal as he says here,
where do we consider natural reason?
Which tells us that men being once born
have a right to their preservation and
consequently to meet and drink and other
such things as nature affords their
subsistence or revelation,
which gives us an account of those gods
grants God made of the world to Adam and
Noah and his sons. It is very
clear that God, as King David said,
has given the,
are to the children of men
giving it to mankind in common.
So we are all equally created by God.
We all have the same rights to the common
as everybody else and there's no sense
in which it's Adam and his ass that have
it's, there's no sense that that Adam
and his as have some kind of priority.
Thirdly,
it's very important for lock and a very
radical move to say that there is no or
authoritative earthly
interpreter of the scriptures.
Anyone guess why might say that?
You know,
there, there may be ambiguities
in the scriptures mean
mmm.
And one person says it means x and one
person sees it, says it means why. Okay,
we have a volunteer over there.
Why,
why is it important for lock to say
that nobody on earth can settle those
disagreements?
Because that person would supposedly
leave be closer to God. Um,
being an interpreter of the word of God,
right. That person would set themselves
up as being closer to the word of God,
being the interpretive that God,
the word of God every man ought to salient
acquiring into himself by meditation
studies,
search and his own endeavors,
attain the knowledge of cannot
be looked upon as a peculiar,
I'm sorry,
I'm mystery every man or sincerely to
inquire into himself and by meditation
studies search and his own endeavors,
attain knowledge of cannot be looked upon
as the peculiar possession of any sort
of man. I think, uh, say a word
has been dropped there, but the,
the meaning of it is that authoritative
knowledge can't be the peculiar,
uh, interpret, uh, possession
of any particular person.
Princes indeed are
superior to men in power.
But in nature equal,
neither the right nor the art of ruling
does necessarily calorie along with it.
The creation of knowledge about other
things and least of all of true religion
for if it were.
So how could it come to pass that the
lords of the earth should differ so vastly
as they do in religious matters?
So political leaders differ with
one another about religious matters.
And that itself tells
you that you can't know.
You can't rely on anybody to saddle
them because nobody has more privileged
access than anybody else
to God's knowledge.
So it's,
it's the beginning of what we will lay
to come to refer to as a Lutheran idea of
the relationship between man and God.
But the idea is that everyone misread
the scriptures for themselves.
And if God wants to speak to you,
he will speak through the scriptures.
And if somebody else
reads them differently,
nobody on earth can
settle that disagreement.
Nobody has the right to
Everybody must settle it for themselves.
And that's going to turn out to be
hugely important in politics because if
people start to believe that the ruler
of this society is violating natural law,
there's nobody who can say they
don't have the right to hold that.
What it means they can do in practice is
another matter that we'll get to later.
So it's going to provide the basis for
the right to resist the authority of the
state, the right to resist sovereign
authority. When we thinking,
think about the Eichmann problem again,
when you are ordered to do something,
just send people to a concentration camp
and your read the scriptures and you
say, well, my reading of the
Bible tells me that this is wrong.
There is no earthly authority.
Who has the right to contradict you?
Tremendously important philosophical
move with huge political consequences.
Of course, there was another
consideration here, um, who not while,
who knows,
uh,
it was not just the disagreements
among the kings and Queens of Europe,
but who else might lock of being
thinking about in the 16, uh, eighties,
uh, not wanting to give authority
to, we're interpreting the scripture,
some history major.
What was going on in England in the 60s,
70s and 80s.
Anybody now
who were they worried about?
Not just the different kings
competing and the authorities? Yeah,
the pope. Yeah. Okay. We don't
need the mic. The pub of course.
Uh,
you will see when you come to read
Locke's letter on toleration, uh, that,
that he has a very wide
view of toleration,
but he doesn't think that Catholics should
be tolerated. We'll get to why later.
Uh,
but the reason here would be that the
pope sets himself up as the authoritative
interpreter of the scripture
and you can't have that. Okay.
You have to have something like what
we would call today at this established
church.
And indeed that takes us to a fourth
source of individual rights in locks
thinking namely that every
individual is sovereign.
The care of Saul's cannot belong to
the civil magistrate because his power
consists only in outward force,
but true and saving religion consists
in the end with persuasion of the mind
without which nothing
can be acceptable to God.
And such is the nature of
the understanding that it
cannot be compelled to the
belief of anything by outward force.
And upon this ground,
I affirmed that the magistrates power
extends not to establishing of any
articles of faith or forms of
worship by the force of his laws,
for laws are have no force at all
without penalties and penalties.
In,
in this case,
I absolutely impertinent because they
are not proper to convince the mind.
The state can control your behavior,
but it can make you believe anything.
And this is the source
of his objection to any,
any earthly authority being
in the position to dictate
what religion requires,
whether it's the king or the pub,
right?
There is no authoritative interpretation
of the scriptures in this world.
Tremendously important move.
So just to summarize,
we have this workmanship idea that informs
the early enlightenment conception of
science.
It's preoccupied with certainty and um,
it's rooted in this creationist theory
of knowledge that we have workmanship,
Workman's knowledge of,
of our workmanship. Uh,
it also translates over into the
theory of rights because justice,
we have workman's just
knowledge about creation.
We also have a workman's
authority over his creation.
We own what we make just
as we know what we make.
Secondly, where we, we own
the right to the worlds, what he's
going to lay to call the waste of God,
what's given to mankind in common just
as little or as much as everybody else.
There is nobody who has a prior claim on
the property out there,
the animals,
the land,
everything that's in God's creation.
We all have the right to use it and
nobody has the right to stop anybody else
from using it, right? We didn't
make it so we don't own it.
God made it and he gave
it to us in common.
This is in contradiction of film,
his view that he gave it
to Adam and Adam's as I've
inherited both the goods and
property in the world and the political
authority in the world directly from
Adam.
So it's this basic idea that um,
we have common rights to the
creation that God has put before us.
Third,
we have equal access to the word of God.
And that's really important because
the word of God or natural law is
what binds all human beings.
We're all his creation and natural law.
His expression of his,
well, we have to obey it.
But what if we don't agree
about what it means? What if we
don't agree about what it means?
That's what the second treaties is about.
We're going to talk about
that in a few weeks, right?
But the important point here
is the sovereign doesn't
have any right to declare
what natural law mean.
So the magistrate to compel us to
believe the received interpretation.
Um,
and finally each individual is sovereign
over himself because true and saving
religion as he puts it consists
of inward persuasion of the mind.
You can't be made to believe things
and it's your authentic belief that
something is the right answer,
which is essential to its
being the right answer.
And this is going to supply the basis
for the right to resist the right to
resist the authority of the state.
That is ultimately,
uh,
the right on which locks
political theory is constructed.
So this workmanship ideal
informs the theory of knowledge.
And the theory of rights, and we are
going to see that it doesn't go away.
People try to secularize it and we're
going to explore the ways in which that
they do that. Um, if considerable lang,
but um,
they try to modify it as well,
but it doesn't go away.
And you'll see that one of the reasons
it doesn't go away is that problematic as
it might be. And it, and there
are many problems with it.
Very few people,
very few people in this room I will bet
are going to ever want to give it up in
Kylie.
Okay.
So we'll start knocking next Wednesday
with classical utilitarianism,
the first of our enlightenment traditions.
See you then.